Aujourd'hui est un grand jour j'ai décidé
de retrouver mon père.
Je me suis dit qu'il avait pas pu partir bien
loin à chercher des cigarettes alors j'ai
pris une carte de France et puis j'ai vu les
gorges de Daluis. Il aimait bien tout ce qui
luit. Manu Dibango me voici partie sur la
route et 7 jours de voyage seulement plus
tard je suis au cœur du petit Colorado niçois.J'y
ai retrouvé ma meilleure amie Marie Wild.
Dis Marie tu veux être mon amie ? Oh bah
à choisir je préfère mourir. Ainsi que
nos guides Coline et Maxime qui connaissent
le coin comme leur roche. Alors bonjour à
tous je suis sur le terrain avec Maxou je
peux t'appeler Maxou ? non. Est-ce que tu
peux nous raconter la géologie du terrain
? Pas du tout non. Merci Maxou. Nous voici
donc partis tous les 6 sur les traces de mon
papa. Papa?
papa?
En parlant de traces, Maxime en a trouvé
des belles qui sont même mes trois figures
géologiques préférées au monde. J'en connais
quatre. Ce que vous voyez là c'est l'équivalent
de ce qu'on observe à la plage quand la mer
fait apparaître des petits boudins dans le
sable là. Ce genre de figure ça s'appelle
des rides de courant et ça peut fossiliser
tel quel. Celles-ci ont 280 millions d'années.
Du coup là on marche aujourd'hui il y avait
une mer. Mais j'en ai déjà une de mère,
c'est mon père qu'on cherche. Alors on va
continuer notre route jusqu'à ces mud cracks.
Ouais là on est obligés de s'arrêter parce
que ceux qui me connaissent savent à quel
point j'adore ça. Là on était dans une
pleine lagunaire donc un peu la transition
entre mer et sable comme on peut connaître
sur les franges côtières maintenant. Et
donc là on avait de la vase, de l'argile.
On a connu un épisode de sécheresse très
important ce qui a permis de craquer cet argile.
Et donc ce craquement il est resté aujourd'hui
après 280 millions d'années dans la pélite.
Il s'est fossilisé comme on peut le voir
sur cette plaque. Et voilà comment naissent
les mud cracks. Craquelures de boue en bon
français mais les géologues préfèrent
utiliser le terme anglais pour moins passer
pour des blaireaux parce qu'on n'a pas trop
besoin d'en rajouter. Mais c'est pas tout
! Il s'en est passé des choses à cet endroit
et à cette époque puisque regardez ça c'est
exceptionnel c'est incroyable c'est fantastique,
ce sont des gouttes de pluie fossilisées.
Enfin plutôt des traces de gouttes de pluie.
On avait un climat tropical donc chaleur et
beaucoup de pluie. Et là c'est ce qui s'est
passé sur cette plaque d'argile. Il y a 300
millions d'années, une pluie intense de type
tropicale est tombée sur cette plaque, ce
qui a permis de faire les traces de gouttes
de pluie qu'on voit ici. La pluie c'est interrompue
d'un coup, ce qui n'a pas permis le lessivage
de l'argile. Donc c'est pour ça que sont
restés ces petits fossiles de gouttes de
pluie. Merci. Un avis sur cette explication
? J'ai trouvé ça merveilleux, merveilleux
vous m'entendez???
J'étais déjà emballée par ce voyage initiatique
quand soudain je découvre cet indice sur
le sentier. Pas de doute, nous sommes sur
la bonne piste. Papa n'est plus très loin.
[Musique inspirante]
Le papa de la petite Valentine est demandé
dans la réserve le papa de Valentine merci.
[Musique héroïque]
Mais alors qu'on cherchait mon père, voilà
qui on trouve encore ? Une mère. Cette fois
c'est la mère de toutes les extinctions.
C'est le surnom qu'on donne à l'extinction
de masse la plus violente que la Terre ait
connu.
Juste derrière moi on peut voir le contact
entre deux roches. En rouge la pélite qui
caractérise l'ère primaire, une ère géologique,
qui est juste derrière moi. Et au-dessus
on peut voir la différence avec une couche
de quartzite plutôt. Ce contact entre ces
deux roches caractérise un bouleversement
géologique il y a environ 250 millions d'années.
Pendant ce contact 95% de la vie a disparu
sur Terre. Oui vous avez bien entendu : jusqu'à
95% des espèces marines et terrestres rayées
de la carte. On sait pas exactement pourquoi
ni si c'est dû un événement catastrophique,
une dégradation progressive des conditions
de vie ou les deux à la fois. Grosso modo
on sait juste que l'atmosphère s'est appauvrie
en oxygène et que la température était
chaud bouillante. Jusqu'à 60 degrés sur
les continents et 40 degrés à la surface
des océans. D'après certains chercheurs,
ce climat aride et chaud serait dû d'une
part à une activité volcanique débordante
qui aurait recraché plein de trucs conviviaux
dans l'atmosphère comme du CO2 qui comme
chacun sait augmente l'effet de serre et donc
réchauffe le climat. Mais une autre cause
éventuelle de ce dérèglement climatique
est plus rigolote : la tectonique des plaques.
Au Permien, quasi toutes les terres émergées
se sont rassemblées pour former la Pangée.
Du coup il y a moins de kilomètres de côtes
et la plupart du territoire subit un climat
continental pas franchement sympatoche. Par
ailleurs des chercheurs ont trouvé pas mal
de nickel dans les sédiments de l'époque,
nickel qui aurait pu être rejeté par les
volcans très actifs du moment, les trapps
de Sibérie, et qui auraient pu empoisonner
les végétaux. Du coup si les végétaux
s'effondrent, ça se répercute sur toute
la chaîne alimentaire bam bam bam bam [musique
bam bam] et paf crise mondiale. Quelle que
soit la ou les causes de cette extinction,
je vous rassure, même si la vie a mis 100
millions d'années à s'en remettre quand
même, elle s'en est remise. Peu après, la
Pangée se disloque pour former la Laurasia
au nord et le Gondwana au sud séparé par
l'ouverture de l'une des premières mers sur
Terre la Téthys, l'ancêtre de la Méditerranée.
Donc là je me situe littéralement là où
la première mer s'est ouverte. C'est fou
de se dire ça non ? Moi je trouve ça fou.
[musique de fête]
Et voilà l'histoire de ce paysage martien
dans lequel la vie a pu s'adapter. Et c'est
Marie Wild qui va nous raconter tout ça.
On va vraiment faire ça ? Oui. Alors Marie
les cailloux ça va 2 minutes mais ça ressemble
à quoi ce qu'il y a dessus ? Et bah niveau
faune et flore c'est assez particulier sur
ce genre de site. On sait que c'est une roche
friable qui retient peu de nutriments et peu
d'eau. Du coup on va surtout avoir une flore
comme on retrouve dans les Landes donc du
genévrier du thym des planaromatiques etc
et au niveau de la faune on va avoir vraiment
une faune méditerranéenne et alpine donc
on peut retrouver du chamois comme du lézard
osselé. Et il y a deux espèces d'escargots
qui sont endémiques d'ici et qu'on a pu voir,
ils sont incroyables ces deux petits escargots
qui s'appellent la marbrée des pélites et
le maillot des pélites. Ils sont vraiment
mimétiques avec la roche ils sont rouges
vraiment tout petits et c'est assez fou. On
les retrouve vraiment que ici. Je vous mets
exactement maintenant des images d'escargots
que j'ai pu filmer ici. Essayez de trouver
le maillot des pélites. Et maintenant essayez
de trouver le marbré des pélites. Bon en
vrai on les voit vraiment bien. Mais ils sont
vraiment rouges et collés à la roche et
voilà c'est cool. Si vous voulez plus d'informations
sur pourquoi mon chapeau vient de tomber et
sur les machins qui vivent allez voir la chaîne
de Marie Wild et sa vidéo. N'hésitez pas
à liker et mettre des commentaires et AAAH
la nature !
Bon donc si je résume on a des figures géologiques
incroyables, un pan de l'histoire avec un
grand P pistoire ? avec une extinction de
masse et des adaptations du vivant à ce décor
martien. Mais c'est pas ça qui va me ramener
mon papa. Heureusement Maxime a la solution.
Car au milieu de tous ces cailloux, il y en
a qui brillent plus que d'autres. Et comme
mon papa est un diamant, s'il est quelque
part c'est probablement dans une mine comme
par exemple celle-là.
Sur la réserve on a des mines qui ont été
exploitées il y a environ 4500 ans et elles
ont continué à être exploitées ensuite
jusqu'à il y a 200 ans à peu près. Et dedans
on a également fait des découvertes majeures
pour la science et notamment pour la minéralogie.
Il a été découvert 70 espèces de minéraux
dont 9 nouvelles pour la science qui n'avait
jamais été décrites, et notamment la Gilmarite
ou la rouaïte. bonjour
Donc dans ces mines, ce qui est assez exceptionnel
c'est qu'on a des filons assez conséquents
de cuivre natif et qui sont des filons hydrothermaux.
Reprenons notre vieille mère, la Téthys.
A partir du Cénozoïque la mer commence à
se refermer et de ce chamboulement tectonique
naît la ceinture alpine, qui s'étend du
chalet de votre tonton savoyard jusqu'à l'Himalaya
et au-delà. Vous imaginez bien qu'un mouvement
pareil ça cause du grabuge dans les cailloux
du coin et notamment dans la région, la surrection
des Alpes a créé des tas de fractures dans
la roche. Fractures dans lesquelles ont circulé
des fluides chargés d'éléments comme le
cuivre l'arsenic l'argent ou le mercure. Ces
éléments sont ensuite déposés dans les
fentes et que s'apelerio filon hydrothermal.
J'avais très envie de voir ça en vrai, surtout
que parmi les minerais de cuivre qu'on trouve
là-bas la malachite et l'azurite font partie
de mes trucs préférés alors imaginer les
voir dans leur habitat naturel ça me titillait
un peu. Mais on n'a pas pu aller voir les
grottes en question vu que bah faut y aller
en rappel et que j'avais pas très envie de
mourir, alors Maxime nous a emmenées plutôt
là. Une autre grotte dans laquelle on aurait
pu voir ça ça et ça, mais à la place on
a vu plein d'autres trucs.
Vas-y c'est parti.
[Musique triomphante]
Ca va je te gêne pas ? - Parfait !
[Musique émotion]
Reflétant sur cette journée, je me trouvais
tout soudain mitigée en mon for intérieur.
Mon cœur de géologue était ravi d'avoir
pu croiser tant de curiosité, mais ma rate
de fille se posait encore trop de questions.
Où était mon père ? Pourquoi était-il
parti ? Se souvenait-il de moi ? Avait-il
refondé une famille ? Quelle est la conductivité
thermique du cuivre ? Combien de tiens valent
mieux que toi tu l'auras ?
[Musique émotion] je m'apprêtais à renoncer,
le cœur gros et les pieds ampoulés, quand
soudain, ma vie bascula. [Musique puissante]
On fait pas ça dans les rivières, merde,
les poissons.
[Musique dramatique]
Papa !
C'est du gneiss.
Ca ira ?
Je te fais un petit plan dramatique.
C’est l’heure du partenaire de cette vidéo.
Merci Nord VPN d’exister et aussi d’avoir
rendu cette aventure humaine possible.
Vous ne connaissez sans doute pas Nord VPN,
alors je vais vous le présenter. En deux
mots : quetsche, bidet. En un peu plus de
mots : pur race, poil long, très câlin,
première main, toutes options, jamais servi,
dans son emballage d’origine, parfum saindoux
ou rémoulade, à saisir.
NordVPN, c’est un VPN qui vous protège
dans la jungle hostile d’internet et qui
vous permet notamment d’accéder à des
contenus inaccessibles dans votre pays. Grâce
à ses 5 400 serveurs répartis dans 59 pays,
vous pouvez vivre l’expérience consciente
de l’internet mondial en un clic. Par exemple,
vous pouvez vous payer la tête des bobos
dans vos vidéos et le soir venu, vous connecter
via NordVPN au site de la BBC pour regarder
des séries anglaises avant qu’elles n’arrivent
en France tout en sirotant une petite IPA
sur votre canapé en palettes. Ô ironie.
Ainsi, si vous voulez naviguer en toute sécurité
sur l’océan du web, tels les passagers
du Titanic en leur temps, choisissez Nord
VPN ! Le premier mois est satisfait ou remboursé.
Mais en plus, grâce à mon lien en description,
nordvpn.com/sciencedecomptoir, profitez de
4 mois offerts sur tout abonnement de deux
ans ! C’est exceptionnel, c’est pour vous,
c’est maintenant, allez client achète.
4 mois, c’est 122 jours, 2 928 heures que
je vous offre. C’est presque une demi-grossesse,
et c’est aussi le temps qui s’écoule
réellement quand vous ouvrez Tiktok juste
pour 5 minutes.
Donc oui, 4 mois offerts ! Contrairement aux
femmes qui l’ont bien mérité, cette offre
est imbattable. Alors n’hésitez plus, allez
tout de suite sur nordvpn.com/sciencedecomptoir,
ou cliquez sur le lien en description de la
vidéo. Faites-le pour vous. Et un peu aussi
pour moi. Nordvpn.com/sciencedecomptoir !
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout cette
aventure haletante. Mais ce n'est pas fini
car le deuxième volet de cette trilogie en
deux épisodes et chez Marie Wild. On se retrouve
là-bas tout de suite ! [La gêne s'intensifie]
Trois mots pour définir ta chaîne. Euuuh...
Ok ça fait un. Biodiversité et truite. [Chifoumi
de la biologiste et du géologue sur une musique
épique]